alright, this is a pepper panic saga level 85
walkthrough video. it's a difficult level that a lot of people
get stuck on
you have a low number of moves to
open up this board in order
to collect all these orders
it's pretty difficult to do if you don't
get
a good start. what you're trying to do in
the beginning its previous to read
papers from the I so that you can make
these two matches
open up the board so
you have to make matters in this small
area here
-ism you don't have a lot of choices but
you just wanna try to look for matches
at all clear
to roser to call that a time or whatever
like here
I can move the red one up the middle
clear out both these
reason you do that is because a lot of
the
explosion that and get more cum from one
the papers drop in the board
and you don't have enough moved actually
if you don't get some help
actually legal remove this number
nothing really exciting
have been there
is the like right around here when you
get to
could really use up to move to open the
more drove around when you get here
it's going to be really difficult
crucial and you can see we did make a
mistake sorry the realistic get a good
rapport
as they fell over the place
but that's the last explosion that we
needed
so now the red peppers Brea here but
because it took so many movies but I'm a
cartoon toppers were gonna have three
left
so you have to match the greenside first
reason you do that is because that
growth this yellow pepper big enough
that will match it
it will Expo you see the green with it
Expo
the exploratory opens up the
or at the bottom
you want to get a have a panic here i
mean there's no way that you can infer
the that's another thing that can happen
to pick it up for them
the normal with you if you don't get a
reaction there
okay so
when you have a few more movies these
decisions here
can be the difference between completing
it failing a
says we don't have a lot of moves in the
borders and set up while
you can see we have yellow peppers which
are you so this makes the in
in the area
we have one stage five red pepper but we
don't have anything the match it with so
you know our chances are pretty low
complete Lori here there's no big
mess down here that's gonna like open up
the space
immediately some is going to explode
this red pepper
that it vertically because that bring a
few
more covers a and
maker here and as you can see there's
some chairs
there's a summit elsewhere you're not
gonna for the first level all fired up
again
and see if we can get a faster start
alright same strategy
right so we think it's warm dry out
there we make it another world
okay so that's much better wheatly out
more in
it and we have another explosion set up
so when you're able to open up the board
this fast
this is where you really have to make
things Carroll
you won't be able to do it every time so
when it does happen
you want to really pay attention to how
you make your choices
if you remember last time we had to
remove that this ever going to have six
and like I said hopefully we'll catch up
a prepared great here
and pick up some verbal orders as well
I every muscle rumors will get a second
when you're at it
on that can happen from time to time it
you you know what will happen often
enough that you can actually
count on it but a
because the way the borders that up you
know it
there's know it happens
after love all rights and I we have
disagree
chancellor for this year to get two more
paper bearing NYMEX goodnight red
peppers
for a blue peppers and we have six mu
arm
skin the board there's not really
other no color actually stands out as
being the best wanna go where
we have a couple stage wars but they're
not the same color
since we have the extra moves
I'm gonna make this L first are
just because there's no real action
movie they're here
and this will clear out the cinema space
we make it something else whatever
peppers although and it didn't but
but that's fine America had amassed them
purple here because of their make
bloomer
and then that
you see that drops for the red in the in
Berkeley
and those little decisions are really
where the
you know where company or the UN
officials are not finishing it
you have to really look around and see
what's going to happen as a result the
beach where your matches all rights and
I we just the more more paper panic
6 red pepper there's not a lot of red
peppers on the board
and none of them were grown except for
these rules right here
so that gives us an interesting choice
because we can
we can match the red with the shock wave
a clear other birthdays
but it's also going to remove more or
grown paper
or we can imagine here and that ok so
this paper and
road again I think since its not
I think in most cases if we had more
grown red peppers on the board then this
would always be the best match
because we have a better chance it a
reaction the census is
is kinda jumbled up on the go ahead and
make the this the big matches
clear out the call another thing to keep
in mind is like
with only five red to explore
we can really start to panic with the
color we don't have to to focus solely
on the
the reality is %uh this
current situation though the that
there's no other better color or
this time I'm going
this summer make this match are for the
same reasons I mentioned before a drop
some papers in the spaces
mall that disrupt this and
this would be the quickest way to get
these
case and I see we have 25
five-state States prior to the other
board and then we have a couple other
good ones here
so now by exploding
this red wine we should get a good chain
reaction and service me with that rather
than earlier
Adam mess the purple I just get a little
bit more space in
makes it more likely that other things
up
and that's how you do it um obviously it
helps
a lot to get those first couple
explosions with the red peppers
quickly that being said you can
you can completed the class les Moonves
but you know you really have to think
out your move after
because I am it's not likely to finish
it by law
as far as just moving a random making
random acts as a
open things for the place where you
really do have to the think your way
through that last part
and you know that like we said in our
full pepper panic saga level 85 guide from
Pepper Panic Tips
that's the only part of the level where
you actually have control the beginning
part
other than clearing the maximum outer
space with her matches there's really
nothing
you improve your chances there's going
to be times when you get good jobs is
going to be time for the bedrock so
focus on what you can and the I hope to
complete level soon
it's really not as bad as it seems that
for but I'll
me a little bit helps from the papers
and need to make a decision
alright thanks